Das ist "Mona mittendrin ―
Im Brocki der zweiten Chance".
Mit Untertiteln
von SWISS TXT
Es geht gleich los: Ich bin bei Rolf
eingeteilt, um Preise anzuschreiben.
Was bringst du da?
- Also ...
* Metallene Geräusche *
Das Erste, was ich mache:
Ich räume einfach ein paar Dinge
auf meinen Tisch.
So habe ich einen Anhaltspunkt.
Ich mache das gleich leer.
Dann kann ich die angeschriebenen
Sachen da reinstellen.
Ich breite alles aus, um mir
ein Sichtfenster zu erstellen,
was dann alles
ungefähr denselben Preis haben kann,
um die Sachen
rationeller anschreiben zu können.
Der Preis hier: Die Eierbox könntest
du mir für 1 Fr. anschreiben.
Aber wer macht die Preise?
Ich.
- (Lachend) Du?
Bist du der Chef,
dass du sagen kannst, was das kostet?
Nein, aber ich schaue,
was es neu kostet.
Du machst also den Preis.
- Ja, im Moment für diese Sachen.
Wie lange arbeitest du schon hier?
- Ich bin im fünften Jahr.
Ich war früher auf dem Markt tätig.
Ich verkaufte Haushaltsartikel.
So Gemüsehobel? Wirklich?
- Genau.
Gemüseraffeln. Aber nicht den.
Warst du Marktschreier?
- Ich war Marktschreier.
Ehrlich?
- Gemüseraffeln ...
Ich verkaufte
diverse Haushaltsartikel.
Das ist eine einfache Raffel,
die aber sehr vieles bietet:
Du hast einen Fingerschutz
und mehrere Möglichkeiten,
dein Gemüse so zu machen,
wie du das möchtest.
Ich will das jetzt nicht vorführen.
Ich dachte,
jetzt komme der Jahrmarktverkäufer.
Aber ich habe keine Produkte,
kein Gemüse,
mit dem ich das Resultat
vorführen könnte.
Wenn du das im Internet bestellst,
kostet das zwischen 39 und 49 Fr.
Im Onlineshop.
- Ja.
Wir machen das zwischen 8 und 15 Fr.
Hier würde ich jetzt 9 Fr. machen.
Jetzt drücken?
- Jetzt ist gut. Rüberziehen.
Siehst du! Du drückst,
dann kommt der Preis raus.
Und dann klebst du ihn drauf.
- Ja.
Eine normale Waage.
Wie würdest du sie anschreiben?
5 Fr.
- Du kannst 3 Fr. anschreiben.
Okay.
- Noch günstiger.
Ich hätte da mehr verlangt.
Im Verkauf sind die
zwischen 15 und 25 Fr.
Nur einen Preis.
- Du warst vorher auf dem Markt.
Genau.
- Und dann?
Vor dem Markt war ich
im Aussendienst Verkaufsleiter.
Ja. In welcher Branche?
- Lebensmittel.
Dann machte ich
noch die Managementausbildung
und wollte im Kader
weiter nach oben kommen.
Damals kriegte ich plötzlich einen
neuen Chef aus der Westschweiz.
Der wollte etwas von mir.
Wenn ich aber Nein sage,
gibt es kein Jein.
Wenn ich Nein sage, meine ich Nein.
Okay.
- Mach 6 Fr., vier Teile.
Er sei noch nie
ein Angepasster gewesen, sagt Rolf.
Nach dem Streit mit seinem Chef
gab er die Karriere
als Verkaufsleiter auf,
machte sich als Marktfahrer
selbstständig
und steckte seine ganze Energie
in den Beruf.
Aber funktionierte es irgendwann
einfach nicht mehr?
Ja, nein ...
Das war vor rund zehn Jahren.
Da machte ich so viel gleichzeitig -
neben dem Markt.
Am Abend nach dem Markt
mit Krawatte ein Seminar gegeben,
am Morgen wieder auf ...
Zu viel auf einmal.
Ich kriegte ein Burn-out.
- Okay.
Dann zog ich mich zwei Jahre
komplett in meinen Wohnwagen zurück.
In diesen zwei Jahren öffnete ich
keine Post, nahm keinen Anruf an,
pflegte keine sozialen Kontakte.
Wovon hast du gelebt?
- Von allem, was ich noch hatte.
Irgendwie über die Runden kommen.
Ich hatte kein Geld mehr.
Krankenkasse ...
Die Steuern wurden eingeschätzt.
Und es wurde immer mehr.
- Okay.
Jetzt habe ich
über 100'000 Fr. Schulden -
von fünf Jahren
keine Krankenkasse bezahlen,
mit all den Gebühren, die sie dir
aufbrummen, Betreibungskosten usw.
Steuern, die nicht bezahlt wurden.
- Ganz genau.
Meine Mutter drängte darauf,
weil ich kein Geld hatte,
um Nahrungsmittel zu kaufen.
Sie sagte: "Du hast jahrelang mit
gutem Einkommen Beiträge bezahlt."
"Du darfst keine Hemmungen haben,
das zurückzuholen."
Hilfe anzunehmen.
- Ganz genau.
Hilfe annehmen
ist für viele nicht einfach,
v.a., wenn es um Sozialhilfe geht.
Das klingt nach Versagen,
nach nicht mehr gebraucht werden
und abgestempelt sein.
Der ist so speziell,
der kommt hier oben hin.
Den sieht auch
der Hinterste und Letzte,
wenn er die Augen
nach oben schweifen lässt.
Ein Ehrenplatz.
- Ja.
Deine Raffel, die du brachtest ...
- Wo kommt die hin?
Hier oben,
damit der Kunde sie gut sieht.
Beim Rumschauen lösen sich meine
Brockenhaus-Vorbehalte in Luft auf.
Es solle wie in einem normalen Laden
sein, sagte Rolf.
Mief und Ramsch haben keinen Platz.
45 Leute arbeiten hier
in einem Arbeits-
oder Sozialintegrationsprogramm.
Ich bin sicher, sie entdecken auch
immer wieder das eine oder andere.
Was habt ihr schon alles mitgenommen?
Viele Kleider für meine Tochter,
meine Schwester, meinen Göttibub.
Ja.
Meine Frau sagte mir sogar,
ich müsse stoppen.- Ehrlich?
"Ich oder das Brocki."
"Du musst dich entscheiden."
- Genau.
Wir kommen auch günstig dazu.
- Ja.
Wir sind ja alle vom Sozialamt.
- Genau.
Alle, die hier arbeiten,
haben Sozialhilfe, oder?
Genau.
Wir brauchen so Orte,
wo wir günstig einkaufen können.
Und was ist besser, als hier ...
... in der Arche für 2 Fr.
ein Lacoste-T-Shirt zu kriegen?
Was ist denn der Grund dafür,
dass man hierher zur Arbeit kommt?
Ich hatte einen Unfall
und arbeitete zwei Jahre nicht mehr.
Ich hatte vier Operationen.
- Was hast du vorher gearbeitet?
Bevor ich meine Tochter hatte,
war ich acht Jahre lang bei Denner -
also, Pick Pay, dann Denner.
Dann war ich alleinerziehend
mit einem kleinen Baby.
Und dann kam ich nicht mehr rein.
Du musst bis 20 Uhr arbeiten,
die Krippe macht aber um 18 Uhr zu.
Logisch.
- Dann begann der Teufelskreis.
Was heisst das?
- Katastrophaler Lebenslauf.
Erstens: alleinerziehend.
Das ist bei allen
schon das erste Mal: peng.
Okay.
- Das weiss ich aus Erfahrung.
Dann: Unfall.
"Ja, was haben Sie?"
Ich muss nur gehen oder aufstehen
und man sieht es.
Dass du hinkst?
- Dann bin ich weg vom Fenster.
Ehrlich? Ist das so?
Gibt es niemanden,
der einem eine Chance gibt?
Nein. Und dann hatte ich durch die
Basisbeschäftigung drei zur Auswahl:
Arche, Caritas-Markt
und das Brockito in Oerlikon.
Mein Favorit
war vom Arbeitsweg her schon hier.
Ja.
Und dann konnte ich
zwei Wochen später hier anfangen.
Was hat dir das bedeutet,
wieder arbeiten zu können?
Alles.
Sonst hätte ich das Gefühl,
ich hätte irgendwann ...
Man merkt es dann selber.
Ich hörte auch,
dass ich komisch wurde.
Ja.
- Unzufrieden.
Und so
kann ich etwas für das Geld machen.
Das ist super.
Es gefällt mir. Ich bin gerne hier.
Also, gehen wir ...
... in die Annahme.
Muss ich die Maske tragen?
- Nein, hier unten nicht.
Okay, gut.
- Nur im Laden.
Ich helfe Sandra
beim Kleidersortieren.
Wo kommt der Sack hin?
Wenn man ihn noch brauchen kann,
brauchen wir ihn als Abfallsack.
Ich hänge ihn hier hin.
- Okay.
Wow! Hey ...
Als Erstes machst du bei Hosen das -
um zu sehen, ob es noch dicht ist.
Sonst kannst du es wegwerfen.
Wirklich zerstörte Kleider
kommen in den Abfall.
Die geben wir nicht mehr weiter.
Das kommt in den schwarzen Sack.
- Gut.
Legst du da manchmal etwas zur Seite?
Damit habe ich aufgehört.
Du findest immer etwas.
Immer. Auch bei den DVDs.
Ich schaue gar nicht mehr.
Ich gehe einfach weiter.
Und Kleider:
für meine Tochter jeweils.
So spezielle Sachen.
Es hat Sachen, die ...
In der Schule haben alle dasselbe,
weil sie zu H&M oder Migros gehen.
Und sie hat Sachen, die niemand hat.
Teils Unikate.
Findet sie das gut?
- Sie findet es hier mega cool.
Sie kommt auch gerne.
Sie findet es lässig.
Klar,
sie versteht schon nicht genau ...
Dafür ist sie zu klein,
auch wenn sie weiss:
so mit dem Geld,
Sozialarbeit und so.
Sie weiss,
dass ihr nicht viel Geld habt?
Das weiss sie,
aber sie kriegt das nicht zu spüren,
weil ich darauf achte.
Ich habe eine super Mutter, sie
eine super Grossmutter und Patin.
Man weiss, dass alleinerziehend sein
ein Armutsrisiko ist,
auch in der Schweiz.
Und das hast du erlebt.
Wie ist das, wenn man Mutter ist
und dem Kind das Beste gönnen möchte,
man aber gleichzeitig weiss,
dass man zu wenig Geld hat?
Wie ist das für dich?
- Ich musste lernen, einzuteilen.
Meine Mutter
gab mir ganz gute Tipps,
weil wir früher
auch nicht viel hatten.
Ja und ...
Es ist einfach gegen Ende Monat, wo
dann wirklich Existenzängste kommen.
Wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
- Du kriegst Panik.
Wirklich?
- "Wie soll ich das machen?"
Ja, ich habe wirklich gelernt,
mich runterzuholen
und mir zu sagen: "Es reicht schon,
du musst einfach schauen."
"Da einschränken, da einschränken."
- Ja.
Ich will einfach, dass es
meiner Tochter an nichts fehlt.
Ja, so Flecken
sind immer ein Problem, oder?
Genau.
Hier unten muss es vorwärtsgehen.
Oben wird es nochmals kontrolliert -
unter besserem Licht.
Du kriegst auch Routine.
Am Anfang ist es schwierig.
Das kommt weg, das ist nichts.
Da hast du ...
* Lachen *
Ich bin etwas vorsichtig,
aber es sind nur Kerzenständer.
Das sind Dinge, die zu Gerry kommen.
- Jawohl, okay.
Darf ich das dir geben?
Das ist aus einem Sack gepurzelt.
Ja, das verarbeiten wir direkt.
Und du kannst mir sagen,
wie ich dir helfen kann.
Das ist die Warenannahme,
die Spenden der Kunden.
Sie bringen es
und bei mir wird entschieden,
was in den Verkauf geht
und was nicht.
Du bist die erste Anlaufstelle.
- Genau.
Ausser, was Kleider sind.
Das geht direkt rüber.
Ja.
- Der Rest kommt hier auf den Tisch.
Lauter Dinge, die aussortiert wurden,
weil man sie nicht mehr braucht.
Da sieht Gerry sogar Parallelen
zu sich und den anderen Leuten,
die im Brocki arbeiten.
Wenn du so Sachen anschaust:
Überlegst du dir,
was für eine Geschichte sie haben?
- Ich überlege mir das genau,
weil ich persönlich
dieselbe Geschichte habe.
Okay.
- Ich habe jahrelang gearbeitet.
Viel gearbeitet.
- In welchem Bereich?
Logistik.
- Ja.
V.a. in der Toni-Molkerei,
bis sie Konkurs ging.
Das Problem, dass du dann hast:
Du gerätst in eine Spirale.
Und irgendwann ist das Ersparte weg,
du musst zum RAV ...
.... wirst ausgesteuert,
verlierst die Wohnung,
weil du nicht mehr zahlen kannst ...
Und du musst immer wieder hören,
was für ein fauler Typ du seist,
weil du keine Stelle findest.
Das trifft mich am meisten.
- Ja.
So wurden es mittlerweile
sieben Jahre.
Also,
seit du deine Arbeit verloren hast.
Genau.
- Ja.
Aber wir sind hier in der Arche
und das ist ...
... gut für meinen Kopf.
- Ja.
Da kannst du zwischendurch
etwas durchatmen
und sitzt nicht nur zu Hause.
Ich bin seit Jahren verheiratet.
Meine Frau
hat auch so eine Geschichte:
Sie war Balletttanzlehrerin,
mitunter im Opernhaus.
Okay.
Sie hatte einen schweren Unfall ...
- ... und konnte nicht mehr arbeiten.
Genau.
Keine Rente, weil sie sich umschulen
und was anderes machen könne.
Sie wollte sich umschulen lassen.
Wir stellten den Antrag auf
Umschulung und er wurde abgelehnt.
Über 50-Jährige
werden nicht mehr umgeschult.
Das wird nicht bezahlt.
- Ehrlich?
Ja.
Und bei dir?
Warum hast du
keinen Job mehr gefunden?
Ganz klar wegen des Alters.
Was sagten sie denn?
Ich kriegte immer die doofen
Aussagen wie "überqualifiziert".
Ich habe in der ...
Ich habe im Kader
dieser alten Firmen gearbeitet.
Du hattest Führungsverantwortung usw.
- Ja, genau.
Das steht halt im Lebenslauf.
Aber letztlich ist es das Alter.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass man gerne hätte,
dass die über 50-Jährigen
schnell den Löffel abgehen,
damit es nicht so viel kostet.
Ich hoffe, es ist nicht so,
aber wie du das erzählst ...
So kommt es rüber.
- Es brauche dich nicht mehr?
Nein, die Gesellschaft
braucht uns nicht mehr.
Wir kosten nur.
650 Fr. Sozialhilfe
erhält Gerry pro Monat.
Für die 60 %,
die er in der Arche arbeitet,
gibt es noch 180 Fr. dazu.
180 Fr. Monatslohn
ist nicht gerade viel.
Aber Gerry sieht das sowieso anders.
Mir wird die Wohnung,
also die Miete bezahlt,
die Krankenkasse ...
Ich arbeite 60 % für
das gesamte Geld, das ich kriege.
Also arbeitest du
auch für die Sozialhilfe.
Ich sehe das so.
- Ja.
Wir sind nicht überbezahlt,
aber es ist doch eine Leistung,
die man bringen kann.
Ist man in der Schweiz
nur etwas wert, wenn man arbeitet?
Eindeutig.
Erlebst du das so?
- Eindeutig.
Es geht nur
über den Erfolg im Beruf.
Trotzdem sollte man den Lebensmut
nicht verlieren.
Wie macht man das?
Es gibt ja auch Gutes im Leben -
auch als Sozialhilfeempfänger.
Und einfach darauf achten,
dass die Gedanken
nicht immer um dasselbe kreisen.
Das kommt weg.
- Das?
Das ist gut. Die sind auch gesucht.
- Die sind super. Die habe ich auch.
Magst du das?
- Du nicht?
Der schlimmste Kaffee.
- Nein!
Dann kannst du nie
bei mir einen Kaffee trinken.
Das würde mir meine Frau
auch nicht erlauben.- Wieso?
Der ist mega lecker. Vorurteile.
- Nein, bei dir Kaffee trinken.
Aha!
Ja, da müsste sie, glaube ich,
keine Angst haben.
So! Zu und auf "Start" drücken -
bis sie läuft.
Gut.
- Das ist eine Schnelllaufmaschine.
Gerry, heute 59, erzählte mir, er
habe Hunderte Bewerbungen geschrieben
und im regulären,
sog. ersten Arbeitsmarkt
trotzdem keine Stelle mehr bekommen.
So, tschüss.
- Tschüss, Gerry. Bis morgen!
Tschüss miteinander.
- Tschüss, Gerry.
Die Gespräche von heute
geben mir zu denken.
Wie wenig es braucht:
den Job verlieren,
keinen neuen mehr kriegen
und plötzlich findet man sich
am der Rande der Gesellschaft wieder.
Um 8 Uhr geht es wieder los.
Guten Morgen. Ich bin Adi.
- Mona. Freut mich.
Yonas.
- Ich bin Mona.
Grmai.
- Freut mich.
Also ...
- Und, bist du fit?
Ja, ihr auch?
Nein, was brauche ich da?
- Das siehst du dann.
Was machen wir denn?
- Wir räumen eine Wohnung.
Eine Dreizimmerwohnung.
Da sind ein paar schwere Möbel drin.
Okay, gut.
Also, ich freue mich.
Super, ich mich auch. Gehen wir.
- Gut, los!
Wir gehen.
- Okay.
Adi ist der Teamleiter
des Transports.
Ich helfe ihm heute.
Das Arche-Brocki macht regelmässig
Haus- und Wohnungsräumungen.
Zu so einer sind wir unterwegs.
3-1/2-Zimmerwohnung - das klingt
nach eher nicht so viel Arbeit.
* Er lacht. *
Es gibt 3-1/2-Zimmerwohnungen
und 3-1/2-Zimmerwohnungen.
Achtung.
- Du musst kurz aussteigen.
Einfach wegen Kindern und so
schauen.
Ja.
Häufig
sind es Wohnungen von Verstorbenen,
die Adi und seine Leute räumen.
Auch das heute ist so eine.
Welche ist es?
- Die da oben.
Die Angehörigen erwarten uns.
Sie sind heute das letzte Mal hier.
Hallo.
- Hallo. Wir sind da.
Ja, gut.
- Hallo.
Ihr habt schon ziemlich aufgeräumt.
Wir haben eigentlich alles
ausgeräumt.
Da kommt einfach alles weg?
Vorhänge ...
Alles, Vorhänge, Lampen ...
- Auch die Lampen, alles.
Der Teppich auch? Alle?
- Auch. Alle Teppiche.
Frau Mächler
ist in dieser Wohnung aufgewachsen.
Zuerst lebten ihre Eltern,
dann später ihr Vater
und seine zweite Frau hier.
Es ist schwierig.
- Ja.
Es ist etwas,
das eigentlich immer da war.
Wir wohnten auch in der Nähe.
Also, ich mit der Familie.
Wir waren sehr oft hier.
- Ja.
Es ist eigentlich mein Zuhause.
Ja, das glaube ich,
dass das wie etwas ist ...
Wie ein ...
Es ist ein Abschnitt.
Der zu Ende geht.
- Ja.
Hatten Sie etwas Angst vor dem Tag,
wo dann die Leute vom Brocki
alles ausräumen?
Ja.
Ich habe nicht gut geschlafen.
- Das glaube ich.
Ja, also, dann ...
- Dann ...
Fangen wir an zu räumen!
- Ja.
Gut.
Danke, dass wir dabei sein dürfen.
- Schon gut.
Alles Gute für Sie und Ihre Familie.
- Danke, Ihnen auch.
Danke vielmals.
Dass so gut geräumt ist,
sei die Ausnahme, sagt Adi.
Bei so Wohnungsräumungen
treffe man allerlei an.
Während ich mich
um die kleinen Sachen kümmere,
widmen sich Yonas und Grmai
den Möbeln.
Nur rund die Hälfte
kann das Brockenhaus weiterverkaufen,
alles andere wird entsorgt.
So richtig mega gute Sachen
zu finden ...
... ist eher selten geworden.
Wir sind eine Wegwerfgesellschaft.
Alle gehen
in das schwedische Haus einkaufen.
Das kannst du
nicht mehr weiterverkaufen.
Es ist den Platz nicht wert.
Aber so etwas,
wenn du dir das ansiehst:
Das könnt ihr wieder verkaufen, oder?
Für dich? Hättest du Interesse?
- Nein.
Ich mache dir einen guten Preis.
Ich bringe es nach Hause.
Nein,
das gibt auch Wärme für Zürich.
Das kauft niemand mehr.
Auch den Tisch nicht. Klar,
kann man es irgendwann verkaufen.
Irgendwann kommt jemand.
Aber du hast nicht ...
... Jahre Zeit,
bis die Person kommt.
Ja.
- Im Schnitt drei Monate.
Alles, was nach drei Monaten
noch da ist, kommt weg.
Es ist einfach die heutige Zeit.
Geht es?- Ja.
- Sicher?- Ja.
Okay.
- Ich sage es dir dann morgen.
Du brauchst ja schon ein Andenken.
- Ja, ich freue mich.
* Er lacht. *
Yonas kommt aus Eritrea.
Er ist ausgesteuert
und kommt nur dank der Sozialhilfe
finanziell über die Runde.
Eigentlich sucht er Arbeit
auf dem ersten Arbeitsmarkt,
aber bis jetzt
habe es noch nicht geklappt.
Und Adi?
- Oh.
Er ist sehr nett.
Ich brauche viel Hilfe
in der Schweiz. Ich habe Probleme.
Ich kenne nicht viele hier.
Er organisiert alles für mich.
Er hilft mir.
- Okay.
Wie schwierig ist es für eure Leute,
auf dem ersten Arbeitsmarkt
Arbeit zu finden?
Brutal schwer. Brutal schwer.
- Wieso denn?
Du hast mir gesagt ...
Du darfst es gerne
noch vor der Kamera sagen.
Ich mache den Job
seit eineinhalb Jahren.
Und das sind die besten zwei,
die ich seither hatte.
Noch nie sagte einer,
es kacke ihn an.
Das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Auch nicht: "Keine Lust!"
Zu streng ...
- Kein Zuspätkommen, nichts.
Im Gegenteil! Sie tragen das
alleine auf dem Rücken runter.
Sie sind einfach Arbeitstypen.
In der Schweiz sagt man: "Leute,
die arbeiten, können wir brauchen."
Ja.
Aber auf dem ersten Arbeitsmarkt
haben sie keine Chance.
Was läuft da falsch?
Wenn sie ein Bewerbungsschreiben
machen, sind das zwei Blätter.
Auf einem ist ein Foto und unten
steht "Automechaniker in Eritrea".
Ja, der Nächste!
Der Nächste hat Zeugnisse usw.
Und sie kriegen keine Unterstützung,
das ist das Schlimme.
Ist das so?
Es gibt so viele Institutionen.
Menschliche Unterstützung.
- Ah, das meinst du!
Ich bin auch abends erreichbar,
wenn sie etwas brauchen.
Das ist nicht selbstverständlich,
aber die müssen arbeiten,
sonst kommen sie auf dumme Gedanken.
Das fehlt.
Die meisten,
die ausgestempelt haben ...
Es ist ihnen egal.
Die machen nichts mehr.
"Feierabend, ich werde nicht mehr
bezahlt." Und das ist falsch.
In der Schweiz
ist das Herz verloren gegangen.
Das ist das Problem.
- Okay.
So, uh!
Der Staub von 50 Jahren.
Ein halbes Jahrhundert
hat die Familie hier gelebt,
aber viel Zeit zum Nachdenken
bleibt nicht.
Auch dank Yonas und Grmai,
die für vier arbeiten,
geht es schnell vorwärts.
- Super, merci.
Merci.
Den Kirschlorbeer killen.
In diese Richtung, okay?
- Ja, ist gut.
Achtung!
- Juhu!
Ja, du sollst.
* Lockere Musik *
Kurz vor Mittag ist die Wohnung leer.
Der Schweiz sei das Herz
verloren gegangen, sagt Adi.
Und ich frage mich,
ob es auch darum auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
immer weniger Platz für Leute hat,
die irgendwie aus dem Raster fallen.
Stell sie dort drauf!
Ich bringe sie dann nach vorne.
Hier in der Arche erlebe ich mit,
dass es für Ausländer,
Alleinerziehende und Leute über 50
besonders schwierig ist, einen Weg
aus der Sozialhilfe zu finden.
Ist der kaputt? Der ist so.
Inzwischen
kenne ich mich schon etwas aus:
Die kleinen Sachen kommen zu Gerry.
Das wäre auch noch.
- Noch mehr gefunden. Bürozeugs.
Ich schaue dir über die Schultern,
ob du etwas siehst,
das dich interessiert.
- Du kannst mir helfen.
Jetzt wirst du konkret.
Brauchen wir das?
Bedienungsanleitung.
Es sieht so aus,
als wäre die für das Telefon.
Wo geht Elektro hin?
- Da.
Okay.
War es streng bei Adi?
Hey, es ist schon ...
- ... heftig.
Ja, es ist heftig.
Im Laufe eines Lebens
häuft sich schon sehr vieles an.
Wie ist das mit dem Job hier?
Wird er mit der Zeit langweilig?
- Nein, der ist hochinteressant.
Genau darum, weil hier
manchmal Sachen reinkommen ...
V.a. bei Räumungen.
Teils ist es erstaunlich,
dass es das überhaupt gibt.
Ich mag v.a. Räumungen
von älteren Menschen.
Dort hat es doch noch Dinge,
die aus den 40er-, 50er-Jahren
kommen und das ist spannend.
Gerade so Sachen, wie das hier.
- Zeig mal!
Es ist nichts mehr wert,
aber es ist so alt,
dass es schon wieder wertvoll ist.
Ja.
- Das finde ich spannend.
Ich stelle mir dann vor,
wie sie das benutzt haben.
Ja.
So etwas finde ich auch spannend.
Wer hat noch einen Briefständer?
Den hatte ich auch in der Hand,
als ich ihn versorgte.
Er sieht v.a. auch noch cool aus.
Am Nachmittag
bin ich wieder mit Sandra unterwegs.
Sandra ist jetzt 38.
Sie hofft, dass es ihr bald gelingt,
eine Stelle zu finden.
Aber sie weiss auch,
dass es wegen ihrer gesundheitlichen
Probleme nicht einfach wird.
Und dass sie ihre Verkaufslehre
seinerzeit nicht abgeschlossen hat,
hilft auch nicht.
Du siehst, das ist der Wagen -
der ist angeschrieben -,
in dem wir gestern sortiert haben.
- Genau.
Und du siehst:
Hier ist besseres Licht.
Hier oben
sehen wir Flecken und Fusseln,
die du unten nicht siehst.
- Okay, ja.
Wieso hast du deine Lehre
nicht abgeschlossen?
Wieso habe ich die nicht ...
In kriegte in Oerlikon im Reformfach
noch ganz knapp eine Lehrstelle.
Es war dann lässig.
Also, es sagte mir wirklich zu
und gefiel mir.
Und dann ...
Meine Chefin
war ein ziemliches Biest.
Heute könnte ich damit umgehen, aber
ich kam dort frisch von der Schule.
Ich war als Teenie schon
ein Schlitzohr, das gebe ich zu.
Irgendwann hatte ich Ferien
und sie rief zu Hause an.
Sie sagte meiner Mutter,
ich müsse Inventar machen kommen.
Da sagte auch meine Mutter:
"Nein, sie hat Urlaub."
Da fand ich: "Scheisse!"
und ging einfach nicht mehr hin.
Das würde ich heute nie mehr machen.
Auf zwei Stöcken und 1'400 m2
gibt es im Brocki nichts,
was es nicht gibt.
Die Preise
sind vielleicht nicht ganz so tief
wie in anderen Brockenhäusern,
aber wer hier kauft,
unterstützt
auch ein soziales Projekt.
Leute aus allen Gesellschafts-
schichten treffe ich hier.
Speziell Jüngere
kommen immer häufiger,
sagt Teamleiterin Hanne,
die gerade an der Kasse aushilft.
Warum kaufst du deine Möbel
in einem Brockenhaus?
Dann muss ich nichts Neues kaufen.
Ist das besser?
- Das ist besser, ja.
Spart Ressourcen,
man schont dadurch die Umwelt
und man tut etwas Gutes.
- Hast du das schon immer so gemacht?
Nicht immer, nein.
Aber immer mehr.
- Ja.
Gut, danke.
- Also, vielen Dank!
Bitte.
- Tschau.
Die Sachen, die an der Kasse
durchgehen, erstehen wieder auf -
eine zweite Chance im Leben.
Wie gross ist die Möglichkeit
für die Leute hier,
eine zweite Chance zu kriegen
und im ersten Arbeitsmarkt
einen Job zu finden?
Leute wie Gerry ...
- Gerry hat keine Chance mehr.
Ist das so?
- In dem Alter ... Rolf auch nicht.
Okay.
- Sandra kann eine Chance haben.
Kann? Obwohl sie nicht mal 40 ist?
- Ja.
Für den ersten Arbeitsmarkt
kann sie eine Chance haben.
In der heutigen Zeit,
wo all die "einfachen" Arbeiten ...
... Verkauf usw.,
immer mehr reduziert werden,
kommen gerade Frauen unters Rad.
Die, die Teilzeitjobs brauchen
und nicht irgendwo in einem Büro ...
Migros und Coop
haben auch schon Scanners.
Ist es generell so,
dass immer mehr Leute
aus diesem Arbeitssystem rausfallen?
Ja, ich finde schon.
Es gibt immer weniger Arbeiten
für Leute, die nicht ...
... der heutigen Zeit entsprechend
funktionieren können.
Für sie wird es immer schwieriger.
- Ja.
Und was bedeutet das?
Ich denke, irgendwann
muss die Gesellschaft sich fragen:
"Was machen wir
mit so vielen Arbeitslosen?"
Durch die Corona-Zeit gibt es
natürlich nochmals einen Schwall.
Und man kann nicht irgendwann sagen,
dass alle auf dem Sozialamt
und ausgesteuert sind.
* Melancholische Musik *
Der Keller ist geräumt.
Ich starte meinen dritten Tag
im Brockenhaus Arche schwer beladen.
Ah,
ich bin schon wieder am Schwitzen!
Es ist dann doch noch viel.
Erst dachte ich:
"Ich glaube, ich habe nichts,
das ich wirklich nicht brauche."
Und am Schluss
ist ein ganzes Auto voll.
Schaut nur!
Jetzt gibt's Arbeit, Sandra.
Für dich.- Hast ... Gut.
Sehr schön.
- Für dich.
Ich habe ja angegeben und gesagt,
ich hätte gar nicht so viel,
das ich nicht brauche, aber ...
Dann kam doch viel zusammen.
Sehr schön, danke.
Das ist sicher für dich.
- Danke.
Keller geräumt?
- Ja, schau.
Gerry,
was sagt dein Expertenverstand?
Weg oder ...
Nein, das geht zu Weihnachten.
- Weihnachten? Aha, okay.
Ja, das ist ein Wahrzeichen ...
... der Nordländer, für Weihnachten:
ein Elch.
Da haben wir noch Bücher.
Wo soll ich diese ...
Bücher kannst du
zu den Büchern stellen.
Das ist ...
... ein Schulthek und so etwas.
- Wow!
Nicht schlecht!
- Nicht wahr?
So, dein Elch kommt
in die Weihnachtsgeschichte rein.
Mein Elch erhält eine zweite Chance.
Und wie ist das eigentlich mit Gerry?
Denkst du, du kommst aus der Spirale
mit Sozialhilfe mal wieder raus?
Das wird schwierig.
Man ist natürlich offen dafür.
Ich wäre sofort bereit,
die letzten Jahre wieder einen
vernünftigen Lohn zu kassieren.
Ja.
Aber wir sind nicht mehr gefragt.
Das muss man realistisch sehen.
Da kommst du nicht raus.
Aber ich sehe mir heute noch
Inserate an.
Ich schreibe ab und zu
eine Bewerbung,
obwohl wir nicht mehr müssen.
Wir haben keinen Zwang mehr.
- In dem Alter.
Ganz hast du die Hoffnung
noch nicht aufgegeben.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Aber eigentlich
habe ich sie aufgegeben.
Da, läuft noch.
- Ja.
Es tanzt auch, oder? Schau mal!
- Süss.
Das ist etwas, das läuft.
- Ja.
Das geht zum Spielzeug.
- Super!
Hoi, Rolf.
- Sali.
Und schliesslich lande ich mit meinen
aussortierten Kleidern bei Sandra.
Hast du mit Wehmut geräumt?
Fast mit etwas Scham.
Ich könnte noch so viel mehr geben.
Gerade bei den Kleidern:
So viel, das ich nie anhatte.
Ja.
- Das ist wirklich beschämend.
Das ist halt jeweils so.
Schau, den behalten wir auch.
Der ist noch wunderschön.
Der kommt in die Mercerie.
- Ja.
Der kommt gleich hier hin.
Das verkaufen wir,
wenn's noch schön ist.
Du musst so aufs Geld achten.
Kannst du noch Kleider kaufen?
Shoppen gehen?
Ja.
Wenn ich etwas brauche,
dann brauche ich es
und dann kaufe ich es auch.
So ist es nicht.
Man möchte ja auch sauber aussehen.
Also, so brutal
ist es dann doch nicht, weisst du.
Zahlt der Vater deiner Tochter
Alimente?
Ja, das macht er.
- Macht er das?
Regelmässig und pünktlich.
Ich muss nie nachhaken.
Kein Thema!
Und dennoch bist du schlussendlich
auf Sozialhilfe angewiesen.- Ja.
Das finde ich krass.
- Ja.
Es ist natürlich nicht schön.
Aber weil ich etwas machen kann,
ist es okay.
Ich mache ja etwas für mein Geld.
Eine Zeit lang ...
Du fühlst dich einfach ...
Es ist ein Teufelskreis:
Du fühlst dich nutzlos.
Du findest: "Ich kriege Geld,
während andere arbeiten und
einzahlen, damit ich etwas habe."
Ich sprach früher wirklich böse
über Sozialhilfeempfänger.
Wirklich?
- Vielleicht ist das mein Karma.
Was dachtest du denn?
Ganz böse gesagt: Das seien Leute,
die zu faul zum Arbeiten sind.
Abschaum, also ...
- So dachtest du?
Ja.
Und jetzt weiss ich,
dass es nicht so ist.
Es gibt immer und überall
schwarze Schafe, sage ich mal.
Und wer diese Chance, diesen Weg,
der vom Sozialamt geboten wird,
nicht geht, gehört für mich
heute noch in dieses Rad hinein.
Ja.
Es ist Wahnsinn, was sie machen,
damit man wieder
auf die Beine kommt.
Wer das nicht nutzt,
ist selbst schuld.
Super.
Komm, du kannst noch etwas schauen!
Okay, ja.
So ist es natürlich mega schön.
Wenn du so sortieren darfst,
macht es mega Freude.
Also, dann lasse ich dich machen.
Hoi, Emmanuel.
- Ja, danke.
Ich wünsche Sandra und allen anderen,
dass sie die Chance nutzen können,
wieder eine Stelle zu finden,
aber auch, um zu zeigen,
wie falsch gewisse Urteile
über Menschen sind,
die in der Schweiz
Sozialhilfe beziehen.
Hier im Brockenhaus Arche
erhalten die Leute viel mehr
als einfach
einen finanziellen Zustupf -
nämlich eine Aufgabe, Wertschätzung
und das Gefühl, wieder dazuzugehören.
Das nehme ich
von diesen drei Tagen mit.
Ich habe keine Nerven.
- Was, keine Nerven?
Nicht mehr.
- Und jetzt Feierabend?
(Alle) Ja.
- Haben dir die drei Tage gefallen?
Es hat mir mega gefallen.
Es war wahnsinnig bereichernd.
Danke vielmals!
Und bei euch? Wochenende? Feierabend?
- Ja.
Nach Hause, waschen,
meine Tochter holen.
Und ja, morgen putzen
und am Sonntag Wochenende, ja.
Du schaust aufs Handy.
Du wirst erwartet, Gerry, oder?
Es klingelt gleich.
Ich muss um 16 Uhr
meine Frau anrufen.
Jetzt ist 16.05 Uhr.
Wenn ich nicht anrufe,
ruft sie mich an.
Dann werde ich zusammengeschissen.
- Warum?
Weil wir uns lieben.
Wir müssen uns hören.
Dann will ich dich
gar nicht mehr länger aufhalten.
Ich will nicht
an einem Ehekrach schuld sein.
Sag ihr einen lieben Gruss.
- Ich gebe sie dir.
(Rolf) Dann ist sie eifersüchtig.
- Ich übernehme die Verantwortung.
Das sage ich ja.
Das Fernsehen hat mich
ein bisschen aufgehalten.
* Ruhige Musik *
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021